all right here to exclusively react to
the Democrats Phi's a memo former Trump
campaign associate quarter-page how are
you sir great to see you you're not you
know a traitor to the country you
haven't let me give some background here
so our audience understands by the way
your naval graduate you went to the
Annapolis yes
and you worked you were part of a
foreign policy Advisory Council on the
Trump campaign they met once and you
weren't there
yeah I had a previous meeting scheduled
with some top military leaders very far
from Washington you never met Donald
Trump never communicated with him in any
way no okay
and so you view yourself as a junior
underpaid unpaid advisor okay you did
speak at a commencement ceremony in
Moscow at the New Economics school by
the way President Obama spoke there too
I've spoken at a lot of universities in
Moscow going back 15 years but yeah I
was and you lived there why did you live
in Moscow because in 2004 Merrill Lynch
was you know they moved out in 1998 when
the emerging markets crisis occurred and
so 2004 was the fastest growth market in
the world and so they mean another guy
went over to get the office going you
admitted to law makers and anybody else
to question you and I want to ask you
about it because I don't think you can
talk about it can you certain meetings
you might have had that while in Moscow
you had brief encounters with people
that may have been senior government
officials I said hello you know one of
the other speakers at the New Economics
school was a government official
I said hello as he was walking down the
speed the off of the off the stage
that's the Deputy Prime Minister of
Russia yes ten seconds not even you know
and I've been asking to try to get
footage of that because and I've been
asked about that in various
interrogations you know literally in all
your time on the campaign or not on the
campaign did anybody in Russia ever
suggest you they had negative
information on Hillary not one word
nothing whatsoever and not even a
glimpse of an offer anyone ever suggest
to you in any way that that there was a
hacking that they were
aware of absolutely not you know I heard
about it in a news event you're
identified a lot in this steel dossier
you know yeah
page nine of it says that you held
meetings with two Igor's session and the
president of the Russian energy giant
and Igor I'm gonna say the wrong way the
Vatican the vacant yeah and senior
according to people did that should ever
happen I had not even heard I started
when I heard the word Divi akin asked of
maybe they started they started calling
me a Wall Street Journal that's the
first to called me in July of 2016 and I
started I kept getting these calls from
people for the next couple months until
it finally broke in September is
anything in the steel dossier written
about you true absolutely not a word
not one word no they're completely false
it's it's a laughable joke
absolutely I know trey Gowdy asked you
this what factual inaccuracies stand out
the most against you it's just the
complete ridiculousness of it all
Sean what what do you think you would
have been charged by the special counsel
now if they had any evidence considering
that that that FISA warrant gave them an
opportunity to get every text every
email every phone call you ever made
well that haven't led to an indictment
by now you know I'm not you know I don't
talk about those things but typically if
any anyone would have I've never been
given any information that you know I'm
under any serious consideration you know
over over a recent month so I have no
personal information the Russian
government or anyone associated with it
played a role in the 2016 election you
added that your visits to Moscow you
were never approached by any Russian in
any way shape manner or form what do you
make of the coverage in this country
that has been for the last years then if
that's if that's true what you said
because you set it under oath and you
said it to the House Intelligence
Committee Sean you know I in that
context I have to thank you because you
have been the Edward armor out of this
whole process you know immediate and I
love that comment has been so completely
out of control
going back really a year and a half now
and so your and your team you know they
use
called the Demuro boys you know your
your team with Greg and and Sarah and
everyone I mean to dig dig through and
actually get to the bottom of things I
mean there's a lot of people has the
country been lied to by the media and by
Adam Schiff on a regular basis it's it's
been non-stop absolutely well and that's
the funny thing about this the memo from
from Saturday if it's just a
continuation of the same game the DNC
has been playing since the summer of
2016
you know Michael Steele Christopher
Steele Michael Michaels my friend yeah
never met him never met never met him
yeah okay the government by the way
spied on you four different warrants for
a full year you know what they have on
you you know the emails that they were
able to get is there anything that in
any way would implicate you in any way
to associate yourself with Russians to
impact on elections of this country I
have no fear whatsoever although it's
interesting you know they have these
it's like Mad Libs on this this memo
where they have you typically in Mad
Libs you have to put in a word and it
comes out with a crazy saying but here
you know it's it's already these crazy
ideas and the the 10 page memo and then
whatever is underneath in these blacked
out boxes I'm sure would even be more
crazy so the interrogatories that that
in the case and Great Britain steel cast
out on the truth of his own dossier
big-time yeah and actually and he it's
amazing how these defamation cases mice
myself yours you know
absolutely we usually I'm suing both Inc
which owns Yahoo News as well as
Huffington Post and you know Yahoo and
others by the time this was all said and
done
well it's interesting if you look at
this fake Intel report of January 6 2017
two weeks before the inauguration
attacking you know really throwing up a
lot of dirt on the incoming new
administration and leaving open these
all these questions there's two themes
to it one is the hacking and we all know
I've been happening
and the other is the fake news media
I've my lawsuit right now is focused on
the fake news media and I'm suing
broadcasting Board of Governors which is
the funder for a Radio Free Europe and
we'll see you know I've been back and
forth with DOJ going back many months
now and so far they've been kicking and
screaming but you know I think now that
these you know the truth comes out
they're gonna be more cooperative harder
page will have you back and we
appreciate your time thanks for being
thanks for everything Sean so